this morning there is a desperate rush
to get out of kabul now that the taliban
have seized control of afghanistan video
from the nation's capital highlights its
government's stunning collapse and
stunning is a word here there are scenes
of chaos at afghanistan's main airport
still under u.s military control which
is the only way out for americans and
their allies now the video shows afghans
look at this hanging onto a c-17 plane
taxing at the kabul airport wow it took
just days for the taliban to sweep
across the country charlie daggett has
reported extensively from afghanistan he
visited afghan government forces on the
front lines just last month charlie how
did things fall apart so quickly
yeah it fell apart in less than a month
the taliban offensive was already
underway the last time we were there and
it was triggered by president biden's
announcement that the u.s troops would
be pulling out as promised the taliban
then went on the attack almost
immediately taking over large stretches
of rural areas they were surrounding
these provincial capitals it was thought
then they would hold off launching an
all-out assault
until american forces were gone for good
but then the real blitz started just
over a week ago the first big city to
fall was kunduz
that cut off all areas to north of kabul
and that was a big victory partly
because it's where the taliban has met
resistance in the past
then one after another afghanistan's
biggest cities outside of kabul were
captured herat to the west
kandahar to the south ghazni again
really important because it cut off the
main highway to the capital from the
south
so kabul wasn't surrounded but it was
certainly isolated and one of the keys
to the taliban success is the speed of
that offensive the afghan military was
not able to regroup and mount any
serious counter-offensive the taliban
exploited that weakness anthony charlie
you've been embedded with american
forces and with the afghan forces we've
spent billions of dollars building up
the afghan army 20 years of training
them
why aren't they more prepared
well anthony the biggest component was
the severe reduction in us airstrikes in
the past that's always stopped the
taliban in its tracks
and i know this may sound odd after 20
years and all that money but the afghan
military wasn't ready for this because
the model they had developed was too
dependent on u.s backup and we're
talking about close air support in
medevac supplies really important um
when we were last on the front lines
that position that we were in was
overrun within days and they were
begging us they were begging me
for support for u.s helicopters
they also couldn't move special forces
around quickly enough
they quickly lost confidence and morale
there was no leadership and you know
when you're surrounded you're running
out of food and water and weapons no
reinforcements
fighting for a government you don't
believe in dropping your gun and going
home
is a pretty easy decision to make
charlie dagetta with the unraveling
situation in afghanistan thank you
charlie